é um prazer imenso pra mim tá aqui hoje
e por vários motivos né
um dos motivos aqui eu me sinto filho da
ufrj fins graduação aqui e um dos meus
doutorados aqui hoje sou professora da
escola de comunicação e o outro é o tema
é que pra mim é muito especial estar
aqui hoje porque eu tenho um filho
sozinha aqui na barriga e acompanhando
pra gente pensar que a universidade
queremos os nossos filhos ele está aqui
comigo pra sentir essa energia que vai
rolar que hoje bom eu vou falar um pouco
da minha história é pra discutir esse
tema e a minha história
ela como o apresentador colocou eu
passei por dez universidades diferente e
de alguma maneira eu procurava alguma
coisa que eu não encontrava nenhuma eu
fiz graduação aqui depois fiz
especialização mestrado não aqui em
universidades diferentes
cheguei matrícula em três doutorados
depois eu achava que eu não tinha
estudado suficiente achei que eu deveria
ir para fora do brasil foi fazer é
doutorado fora do brasil tradução do
estudo também fora do brasil
depois pós doutorado fora do brasil e
depois passei no concurso da fé rj
mas quando eu passei no concurso da ufrj
como professor ufs uma reflexão muito
difícil que foi que eu não tinha
encontrado em um lugar desses que eu
tinha passado à universidade o que eu
tinha imaginado e imaginado que a
universidade seria um lugar que a gente
trocar se conversar se discute se
estudasse muito né que a vida acadêmica
vida universitária fosse cheia de
encontros e de reflexões e e não foi
isso que encontrei em nenhum desses
lugares que o frequentei e ter passado
do concurso foi um pouco a solidificação
disso muito difícil e eu cheguei a
pensar em abandonar ufrj
porque o que encontrei foi completamente
diferente do que eu tinha imaginado que
era todas essas questões acadêmicas que
muitos devem viver mas um certo
isolamento os alunos desanimados
professores muito desanimado ajudar em
aula
pesquisadores que pensam mais em na
competição dos recursos do que presente
na pesquisa na troca poucas alianças
disputas de poder voltar os tanto na
pesquisa para a concorrência e em
questões políticas associações muito
estranhas pesquisadores e professores
que se associam muito mais pelo aquilo
que eles qualificam do que pelo aquilo
que eles acreditam então tem desde
associações públicas de qualificação
teórica até colegas e grupos rivais
isso foi muito difícil pra mim e aí que
a gente acaba sempre inventam um jeito
de de se reinventar né
e teve um encontro muito especial na
minha vida que foi um lugar chamado caso
a hans staden chamamos assim
carinhosamente que é uma casa em
botafogo que muitos não devem conhecer
mas é uma casa que trabalha com o saúde
mental é uma casa terapêutica nesse
momento você deve estar achando que eu
sou louca né
eu trabalho com um psicótico ou
esquizofrênico ct sempre mas é um
projeto muito diferente muito especial
inspirado em experiências na frança é de
r de leve
laborde que é uma casa onde tem janelas
e as portas abertas 24 horas por dia
freqüentada por pessoas muito diferentes
desde psicóticos parque são pacientes
até terapeutas técnicos acadêmicos
intelectuais artistas e estudantes
vizinhos e essa casa tem uma proposta de
uma vivência muito diferente que é não
só
dá uma possibilidade de vida para essas
pessoas disse saúde mental mas também
refletir discutir estudar junto com todo
mundo está interessado e isso envolve
uma vivência que contempla uma produção
colaborativa de textos artigos
acadêmicos inclusive vídeos é comida
junto festas e foi ali que eu comecei há
realmente encontrar um lugar que eu
imaginava que deveria ser a universidade
esse lugar de encontros e eu frequento
né até hoje muitos grupos de estudos de
filosofia e é uma casa que não é marcada
por lógicas como a do relógio por
exemplo os grupos são de madrugada do
final de semana é tem uma liberdade
muito diferente de qualquer lugar que eu
já tenha ido na minha vida e a questão é
que isso me marcou tanto isso marcou não
só a minha formação pessoal como aquilo
que eu queria ser como professora como
estudante com o pesquisador aquilo que
eu queria que a universidade fosse de
alguma maneira tentei levar isso para a
universidade e eu chamo que isso de uma
ética hecker de alguma maneira eu vi
essa casa uma ética reta e isso tem a
ver com o objecto de estudo porque eu
cheguei pirataria no meu mestrado e
vocês conhecem a ética hacker mas o gol
é um número a alguns valores aqui que
primeiro deles é o compartilhamento
livre de conhecimento uma lógica não
proprietário do conhecimento e das
coisas na construção de um espaço comum
a abertura tanto de processos como de
códigos de informações e essa abertura
até metodológica né descentralização
total horizontalidade não tem ninguém
melhor nem pior que ninguém não tem
líder não tem técnico
os a muitas vezes você nem sabe eu
demorei anos nessa casa
para saber quem era paciente é cliente
quem era terapeuta quem era visitante eu
tinha vergonha de perguntar também
sentiam muito formatada né de perguntar
isso porque a gente justamente tem que
se desfazer desse tipo de classificação
e lugar e olivier conhecimento para
viver melhor então essa casa se estuda
intensamente e de alguma forma isso
influenciou é não só a minha atitude
dentro da universidade como também o
próprio objeto de estudo mas isso eu vou
falar um pouco na frente então a minha
questão era como levar essa ética hecker
para dentro da universidade
pra me reinventar também como
pesquisador e com a professora eu falar
um pouco do de como isso aconteceu eu
queria fazer uma reflexão com vocês
porque a gente vive uma época em que a
gente ouve máximas eu vejo os alunos e e
e muitos professores e produzindo esse
tipo de coisa de que de alguma forma
anunciam a morte da universidade
então a gente ouve coisas do tipo a
universidade não serve pra nada né
é na verdade o que o importante é fazer
ela está totalmente ultrapassada não tem
mais função social
a gente tem que aprender fazendo
é a universidade é teórica demais ela
sempre fica atrás do mercado atualmente
conhecimento que vale o conhecimento
tácito informal é e você pode adquirir
isso sozinho ou vendo o outro fazer é
discutir conceitos discutir algo teórica
teoricamente o conceitualmente é uma
perda de tempo não seja devem ter ouvido
isso todas essas frases uma espécie de
anti intelectualismo que a gente vive e
eu justamente queria propor aqui pensar
com vocês
se é assim mesmo né pra que serve o
pensamento para que serve o pensamento
crítico
então a gente vive numa época de
fast-food faz bem que infesta em estudo
tem que ser rápido temos que dar
respostas rápidas né e eu pergunto pra
vocês será que então o pensamento
crítico não serve mais para nada
será que a gente está numa sociedade
onde as coisas não precisam mais ser
pensado em fazer do jeito que ela
funciona
tá ok o que falta é fazer é tudo uma
questão de gestão falta gente chega lá e
executar no não é preciso questionar
mais porque as coisas já estão
caminhando para o modo como a gente
gostaria cena que a gente vive numa
sociedade assim a gente não precisa mais
questionar a realidade
será que tudo realmente é um problema de
ordem prática de organização
será que a gente pode realmente pensar
que a gente vai começar a resolver os
nossos problemas com tentativa e erro
o agente deve copiar modelos que dão
certo
[Música]
essas questões me fazem pensar se isso
for verdade como é que a gente vai
produzir o novo
como é que a gente vai poder criar uma
realidade que não existe ainda
e se criar uma realidade nova
criar um possível é necessário
pensamento crítico é justamente porque
ele é capaz de desnaturalização a
realidade então a universidade de hoje
vive uma certa pressão que essa pressão
de formação de mão de obra
então as pessoas entram na universidade
com a expectativa de que vai ser um
lugar para se aprender a trabalhar sabe
a verdade é que a gente aprende a
trabalhar trabalhando mas aonde a gente
vai aprender a pensar então pra mim
talvez seja essa grande vocação da
universidade
a universidade como um lugar de produção
de pensamento crítico porque a teoria é
realmente o grande e mais importante
campo de batalha que a gente tem hoje
ela é sempre o campo de luta mais
importante porque é só através da teoria
é só daquilo que através daquilo que a
gente consegue entender e conhecer é que
a gente consegue perceber o mundo
e a outra vocação interessante da
universidade é que na universidade a
gente pode lutar é um dos lugares
possíveis de lutar contra o pensamento
único contra o pensamento do a lista que
seria o próprio inimigo do pensamento
então a proposta é talvez a gente
aprender fazendo da gente fazer pensando
e nada mais importante no nosso país do
que isso hoje não a gente não colocar
soluções tão rápidas eu não sei se a
gente precisa de soluções agora nesse
momento talvez a gente precise refletir
primeiro entender exatamente o que está
acontecendo especialmente do contexto
político que a gente vive hoje então
estudar pra mim serve pra gente viver
melhor pra gente libertar o pensamento
de qualquer aprisionamento para a gente
criar uma realidade nova e pensar numa
coisa tão simples porque não basta você
comprar um livro e ler o livro sozinho
ou e na internet o que realmente
informação disponível para todo mundo
pensar e se necessita do outro você de
troca você precisa de discutir porque
senão você não sai de si mesmo e essa
ideia de ser revolucionário
revolucionário é a palavra vem de
revolução de revolver voltar e dar a
volta em si mesmo pra gente poder se
superar então a gente precisa do diálogo
de pequenas águas e discussão não tem
uma frase muito bonita de um filósofo
que eu acho muito que é o de lei exige
ele diz o pensamento jamais foi uma
questão de teoria mais de vida
então a forma como eu utilizo isso na
onu
felicidade eu tenho um grupo de pesquisa
que chama net leve com alunos
maravilhosos que toparam essa empreitada
comigo e onde costumo dizer que a gente
faz ciência de garagem
é uma tentativa de trazer essa ética
hecker pra dentro da universidade porém
com essas águas de discussão com esses
grupos de estudo com pesquisa não só é
encontros ea gente de alguma forma
hackeia universidade porque a gente
subverte a universidade de várias
maneiras a gente não respeita o relógio
e nem os espaços é tradicionalmente
colocados para esse tipo de atividade a
gente se encontra fora da universidade
final de semana à noite é um trabalho no
projeto de pesquisa do outro enfim a
gente vai inventando uma forma de
trabalhar de estudar e de pensar ea
gente trabalha né
diga-me ser objeto de estudo que te
direi quem és o estudo de redes contagem
micro sociologia ou seja a nossa questão
é entender como que a sociedade muda
então a gente costuma dizer no nosso
grupo que fazer ciência de garage é
produzir e criar é fazer coisas apesar
das instituições e tem um dos conceitos
importantes no nosso grupo que eu queria
colocar pra vocês que eu aprendi na hans
staden e tenta trazer sempre meus alunos
que a diferença entre rigor e rigidez na
universidade se confunde muito esses
dois conceitos na verdade rigor é não
repetir o modelo rigor é resistir a
qualquer situação coercitiva do
pensamento qualquer submissão igor é se
dedicar é dedicação honestidade
engajamento total naquilo que está
fazendo ea rigidez seria o oposto à
rigidez é justamente a seguir à risca o
modelo né a formatação e deixe e copiar
então a gente procura se livrar
completamente da rigidez mas zelar
totalmente pelo rigor
e dois conceitos importantes para a
gente é o contexto de contagem de micro
política porque a gente acredita que de
alguma maneira as coisas mudam através
do contágio a gente vai poder mudar a
universidade através do contágio agindo
diferente e essa ação vai tendo efeitos
em outros grupos em outros alunos e
assim a gente vai criando uma massa
crítica dentro da universidade ou seja
nas relações de troca que a sociedade
muda e o conceito de micro política aqui
pra gente é muito importante que é
entender que é a política que a gente
pode fazer é micro e política no sentido
do beleza que é agir sobre a realidade
tão política no senso comum é dito na
arte do possível pra gente política é
criar o possível é tornar possível então
pra fechar
queria colocar pra vocês uma mensagem
que é eu acho que a gente vive na
universidade hoje uma ausência de
projeto
mas esse projeto ele se complica porque
realmente é difícil acreditar na
universidade tal como ela é hoje ela tem
muitos problemas
muitos esquemas muita rigidez muitos
clichês e realmente do xenapp do jeito
que ela tá ela impede que a gente
entenda enxerga até sua própria função
mas a questão é a gente conseguia
acreditar numa outra universidade e
talvez essa outra universidade seja essa
mistura de uma ética regras de
compartilhamento e horizontalidade e de
pensamento crítico bom fica o convite
[Aplausos]